Es scheint zu schön um wahr zu sein.
Wird die Medizin in Zukunft alles heilen können?
Jede Krankheit, jede Verletzung, einfach alles.
Diese rosige Zukunft könnte durch künstliche
Intelligenz KI tatsächlich Realität werden.
Denn mit Computern werden immer öfter wahre
Wunder vollbracht!
Das jüngste wird die Krebstherapie revolutionieren!
Und dann kommt auch noch Google beziehungsweise
Alphabet ins Spiel mit der Künstlichen Intelligenz
Deepmind.
Die offenbart sich jetzt als Maschine mit
Superkräften.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier berichten wir täglich über die unglaublichsten
Entdeckungen und Fortschritte in der Wissenschaft.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Immer mal wieder lese ich in Kommentaren.
Schon wieder ein Rekord, wieder bahnbrechend,
sensationell, Wahnsinn, Hammer undsoweiter.
Ich solle doch mal mit den ganzen Superlativen
aufhören.
Ich fürchte, dass es aber mehr werden.
Wir leben nämlich in einem Zeitalter, wo
die Forschung und der technologische Fortschritt
sich in immer höherem Tempo entwickeln.
Und das ist wirklich bahnbrechend, unglaublich,
Hammer und abundzu muss ich auch mal “What?”
ausrufen undsoweiter.
Superlative werden wohl in Zukunft zu unserem
Alltag gehören und das ist zum einen extrem
erfreulich und zum anderen auch dringend nötig,
denn ansonsten bekommen wir die riesigen Herausforderungen
auf unserem Planeten einfach nicht bewältigt.
Und dieser Fortschritt könnte tatsächlich
ein Tempo annehmen, bei dem es auf die vorhergesagte
technologische Singularität hinausläuft,
bei der uns die Intelligenz von Computern
bei weitem überlegen ist.
Eine Gefahr, aber auch eine riesige Chance.
Und in einem Bereich kündigt sich diese Entwicklung
schon an.
In der Medizin.
Hier werden immer neue Rekorde aufgestellt
und unmögliche Dinge geschafft.
Ein solcher Meilenstein wurde jetzt wieder
erreicht und der ist absolut bahnbrechend
und zeigt uns auf absolut beeindruckende Weise
wohin die Entwicklung in der Zukunft geht.
Daniel-Adriano Silva von der University of
Washington und sein Team haben eine körpereigene
Substanz für die Immuntherapie gegen Krebs
“weiterentwickelt”.
Und das ist wirklich revolutionär.
Denn die Anführungszeichen bei weiterentwickelt
kann man eigentlich auch weglassen.
Es geht um Interleukin-2, dass eigentlich
ganz wunderbar gegen bestimmte Krebsarten
eingesetzt werden könnte.
Eigentlich, den in größeren Mengen ist Interleukin-2,
obwohl körpereigen, giftig.
Das Forschungsteam hat aber etwas spektakuläres
gemacht.
Sie haben den Stoff tatsächlich weiterentwickelt
und noch eine Steigerung und das per Computer.
Wirklich absolut unglaublich.
Sie haben mit einer Software Rosetta das Protein
immer wieder variiert und verbessert und dann
in der Realität nachgebaut.
So wurde Interleukin-2 immer weiter verbessert
und es schließlich so optimiert, dass es
kaum noch aussah wie das Original und zudem
weniger schädlich und dazu auch noch stabiler
war als das Original.
Bei Mäusen lassen sich damit bereits Darm-
und Hautkrebs erfolgreich behandelt.
Damit werden zwei Dinge offenbar: Erstens
DNA sind Daten.
Mit denen kann man rechnen.
Und zweitens: Ein Computer hat das jetzt mit
überragendem Erfolg getan.
Und jetzt kommt noch ein dritter Punkt und
dafür fällt mir jetzt wirklich keine Superlative
mehr ein.
Rosetta ist dabei noch sehr sehr schwach.
Es gibt bereits einen Wettbewerber, der fast
die 10fache Leistung bringt.
Rosetta ist nämlich eine Software, die beim
CASP13-Wettbewerb eingesetzt wird.
Hierbei geht es darum aus DNA-Sequenzen als
Ausgangspunkt die Proteine zu errechnen, die
daraus entstehen.
Wieviel der 40 Proteine werden korrekt errechnet.
Also wie sehen sie nachher aus.
Das ist in der Medizin entscheiden.
Je nachdem wie sie aussehen oder auch sich
konstruieren können sie gutes und nützliches
tun oder im anderen Fall auch schlimme Krankheiten
wie Alzheimer, Parkinson oder BSE hervorrufen.
Bei BSE sind es zum Beispiel Prionen, atypisch
gefaltete Protein.
Und Falten ist genau das richtige Bild für
den Aufbau von Proteinen.
Es ist ein bisschen wir Origami, nur dass
es nicht um ein paar dutzend Faltungen geht,
sondern um so viele Faltungen, die man brauchen
würde um eine Origamitier in echt und lebendig
zu falten.
Also eine nicht ganz so leichte Aufgabe.
Kein Wunder also, dass der Zweitplatzierte
nur drei der 4o verlangten Proteine korrekt
gefaltet hatte.
Jetzt kommt es aber: Das Team von Deepmind
hatte ja bereits mit Alphago gezeigt, dass
es bahnbrechendes leisten kann.
Es ist der beste Go-Spieler auf der Welt.
Da haben wir ja drüber berichtet.
Für den Faltwettbewerb (Falten heißt auf
englisch fold) haben sie Alphafold entwickelt.
Und Alphafold hat Achtung, jetzt mal wirklich
festhalten 25, der 40 Proteine korrekt gefaltet.
Mehr als die Hälfte, fast die zehnfache Menge
des Zweitplatzierten.
Das ist wirklich Wahnsinn und jetzt möchte
ich wirklich hier mal alle Superlativen abliefern:
“bahnbrechend, unglaublich, Hammer” What?
Das wird die Medizin wirklich revolutionieren.
Dagegen ist die am Anfang vorgestellte Revolution
nur noch ein Revolutiönchen.
Das zeigt wirklich unglaubliche Perspektiven
auf.
Wenn diese Maschine in der Forschung eingesetzt
wird, dann werden solche Fortschritte alltäglich
und die Menschheit wird einen riesen Schritt
in der Krebstherapie machen und in der Behandlung
von allen möglichen Krankheiten.
Das wird wirklich hochspannend!
Genauso übrigens wie dieses Video: Hier klicken
für: Wie intelligent ist Künstliche Intelligenz
von Bytethinks.
Unbedingt abonnieren.
Da gibt es sehr bald neue Videos.
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!